[Music]
[Applause]
the content of this program is to
provide nutrition education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care phys the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel wall
welcome to daily with Doc and
[Music]
Becca
open the doors let
me make sure that we are recording in
progress hello hello
everybody hope you are having a
absolutely
fabulously just right day my name is
Becca dukes and welcome to daily with
Doc now now as the co-host I'm not the
co-host as the hostess of this program
it is my privilege and honor to be able
to bring information to you that is
empowering and I could not do this
without my co-hosts so I just want to do
a special little shout out to them as
part of my
team and making sure that the
information that we bring to you today
is streamed properly out to YouTube out
to rumble
out to Facebook Messenger so if you are
on any of those platforms plus we've got
some others that we're working on as
well I want to know what is your
favorite platform so if you're on live
with us or if you're out in the rest of
the internet somewhere put a comment on
this video and let me know what is your
favorite way to watch information to
watch videos like this I want to get
some collective input so that we can
make sure that we're meeting people
where they're at and making sure that
the information that we're providing is
actually being received in a way that
they can then share it with those in
their Community as well so with that
being said again thank you so much for
joining us here on daily with Doc we
have so many people that are sending in
emails
and messages that we are getting to
those in the order that they are
received there's a couple of them that I
have in process I'm getting information
together that I'm bouncing off Dr Wall
just to make sure that the information
that we are sharing with all of you is
exactly what Dr wallik would recommend
for you as well um I feel very blessed
and honored but it's a
very it's a big job it's a big job to be
able to communicate with Dr wck each and
every day and making sure that this
message is available and that it's being
portrayed
in exactly the way Dr Wall's research
has proven it to work so for those of
you who are waiting for responses thank
you so much for your patience if you are
wanting to ask questions and you're here
live with us feel free to put put your
hand up use that virtual hand on zoom in
Zoom if you're out in YouTube land or
rumble or Facebook come join us here in
the live Zoom go to daily withth do
zoom.com that's daily withth do
zoom.com you can also find that
information on our website daily withth
do.com right there at the top and you
can sign up up for our newsletter with
our newsletter we're not going to flood
your email with a whole bunch of things
um right now we're just doing one or two
or three emails a week sharing
information but the most important one
is coming out on Tuesdays Mondays or
Tuesdays and that is the recordings and
the descriptions of the previous week's
programming so that you have that easily
available to be able to share with other
people now daily withth
do.com is a website that myself and my
team utilize if you were shared this
program by somebody specific make sure
that you get back with them and thank
them for sharing this information with
you because they took the time and they
cared enough to make sure that you had
in just something that you could
actually put into practice in your lives
that would help you write a better
health Journey no matter where you are
on that Journey when you give your body
the raw ingredients that it needs and
takes it out take it out of that
starvation mode the body can do some
amazing things now the FDA does require
us to let you know that the content of
this
program is to provide nutritional
education only this program is not meant
to take the place of your primary care
physician and our products are not meant
to treat prevent diagnose or cure any
diseases but folks as empowered
individuals we do have options and those
options that we are providing with you
today are solutions that many of us had
found to be the the only solution that
helped in our health Journey now we are
guided and we are actually very honored
to be able to have one of the founding
fathers of the science of epigenetics
here to guide us and as becoming one of
the founding fathers of this science
that was decades of research folks
Decades of
research over a 100 Publications now
even
peer-reviewed
Publications that are easily
found on his research and you don't have
to go to the Smithsonian Museum to see a
national treasure that he was very very
much involved in because it was his
thesis in
college diseases of exotic animals well
I'm an exotic
animal you're an exotic animal we were
divinely created and his research
research goes go through and does that
comparative
pathology in
comparing what's present nutrient
wise and what's not present when disease
occurs so Dr Joel wallik welcome to
daily with doc thank you so much for
joining us here
today well thank you so much Becca and
your team great introduction appreciate
that and of course it's a very very
exciting thing to talk about you know
the the researches in the Smithsonian
Institute is a natural treasure that's a
very highly unusual thing so very proud
of that but it is very unique because it
came from autopsies over 454 species of
animals plus humans and so it's not just
an isolated thing so today I want to
talk about something that's
Universal
okay all vertebrates regardless or an
amphibian a reptile a bird or a mammal
okay it doesn't matter uh we all have a
heart heart okay now your heart is a
very interesting organ it beats on the
average you know say 50 to 70 times
depending on your body weight and what
else is going on between 50 and 70 times
a
minute
247 for your entire
life for your entire life it never stops
beating if it stops beating you die just
think about it your heart is working 247
for every day of your life now that's a
remarkable thing when you think about it
and so I want to talk about circulation
there's two pieces of circulation
outside the heart uh number one are
arteries which the heart pumps the blood
throughout the body and then the
arteries get smaller and smaller the
farther distance from the heart to keep
the pressure up and so the little
arteries go into the uh the heart itself
the little arteries go into the eyes the
little artery goes into your tongue the
little arteries go into your lungs your
little arteries go into your liver your
little arteries go into your kidneys
your muscles your bones your
skin all over the place okay and
then the veins start out as tiny little
capillaries and they get bigger and
bigger and bigger as they get closer to
the heart and bring back the blood that
has what has reduced oxygen and food
levels in it okay and and comes back to
the heart so the heart can pump it
through the lungs and get oxygen in it
okay and the of course the intestinal
tract is connected through the veins to
put nutrients and fluid into the veins
which then go back to the heart which
then gets pumped out to the rest of the
body you just think about that heart is
working 247 for every day of your life
50 years 60 years 70 years 80 years 90
years 100 years 120 years 150 years it
goes
247 it's an amazing thing so we got to
take care of the heart the arteries and
the veins now these little arteries they
go into your brain they go into your
eyes um in fact when you get osteoprosis
of the skull and the skull is squeezing
the optic nerve and the optic artery and
the optic vein
you get macular degeneration the macula
is kind of the back part of the eye the
inner lining of the eye the retin of the
eye where the optic nerve comes into the
back of the eyes has a high level of of
of blood vessels high level nerves and
everything but when the skull is
squeezing the optic nerve and the optic
AR and the optic vein that macula dies
it's called macular regeneration then
doctors want to do surgery they want to
give you new glasses and all that kind
of stuff and really you need to be
dealing with the skull okay and so then
of
course um when you have uh let's say
problems with high blood pressure and
kidneys your on
dialysis well that's because the
arteries are blocked in the kidneys
you're not getting these proper
circulation into the little glami which
filter the blood okay get the dirty
stuff out of the blood and put it into
the urine so pee it out all right and um
and then the veins of of course again
bring the cleaned out blood from the
kidneys all the way back up to the lungs
and the and the heart and that's that
cycle and so and then of course you have
to worry about what you eat your doctor
has made a mistake hundred years ago
going on maybe 200 years now okay uh
yeah I'd say it's a little over 100
years maybe 150 years doctors blame
plaque in the arteries you you can see
this in the microscope when you take a a
you know uh make a slide out of an
artery that was plugged you can see that
the walls of the artery were thickened
with a fatty substance and they said ah
this is
cholesterol and they blamed cholesterol
on plugging of the artery so you got to
stop eating eggs stop eating animal fat
and and take these drugs we've come out
with the pharmaceutical industry came up
with
um these drugs to um lower your blood
cholesterol okay
and um is one of those things where they
made a huge mistake okay they've killed
I'd say millions of people okay by
getting them off
of gluten okay they've killed millions
of people by getting them off of gluten
because gluten makes wa wait wait wait
wait wait so they killed millions of
people getting them off of cholesterol
though right sorry thank you cholesterol
thank you thank you thank you Cher thank
you thank you for correcting me yeah
cholesterol yeah they they got everybody
off of the
cholesterol okay um but um then but they
should have kept them on more more
cholesterol and and no gluten gluten was
the problem okay gluten of course was
forced on people when do say you know
the reason why you're constipated you
don't need enough grain eat more whole
grain eat more whole grain eat more
whole grain eat more wheat we and take a
little break have some bucked pancakes
and bucked
for breakfast and
um and so forth and course all these
grains we BR o have gluten in Bad Guys
gluten and it causes all those V in to
go away V little projections and make
line intestin look like a shag rug when
that shag
rug
um go away because you're eating gluten
okay uh your your intestines look like a
plastic you lose 90% of your D of surf
and then you're really in trouble then
you're really in trouble okay it's one
of those things where you got to pay
attention here you must must must eat
eggs of course we have an 926 it says
right on the label provides 20% of your
you know one dose provides 25% of your
dat requirement of cholesterol my doctor
says take my cholesterol
drugs okay no no want to take
cholesterol drugs you want to take the i
26 you want to eat three with soft yolks
not hard B not
fried and people with with plugged
arteries we take people who have really
big trouble um they have not urinated in
10 years okay now they've they've been
in trouble for 25 years been on dialysis
maybe three days a week um for say 10 15
years and then the last 10 years years
they've been on dialysis six days a week
because they haven't urinated at all in
the last 10 years we get them going on a
healthy brain and heart pack we get them
going on the um um let's see here we get
them going on the heal and heart pack we
get them on the alate daily classic
tablets so three of those twice a day
three words timate daily classic tablets
um and that supports healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries supports
healthy blood pressure and suddenly now
after 10 years of not urinating they're
ating and so they drop the dialysis down
from six days a week down to three days
a week and then in two more weeks
they're totally off a dialysis and and
they're going back to normal because
suddenly now the the arteries in the and
the kidneys are working properly and
bringing the dirty blood through the
arteries into the kidneys the kidneys
are filtering it okay and then in the
glami and then the filtered blood comes
back up to the heart and the lungs
through the veins okay that's how the
cycle works works and so this is not a
mystery but it's one of those sad sad
sad things where the medical profession
has not corrected this in over a hundred
years has push in 200 years has not
corrected their mistake that they made
many years ago because they make so much
money okay under the circumstances of
course the pharmaceutical companies love
the cholesterol oring drugs
okay
um this is where the pharmaceutical
companies really made it when the doctor
said you know you got to lower your
cholesterol and they came up with these
um cholesterol lowering drugs and this
is what financed the entire medical
industry okay and so they doctors didn't
want to say we don't know what's going
on here we just need to lower you know
we just need to lower um your blood
pressure we need to make sure you're
urinating we're going to give you
dialysis we're we're going to give you
um drugs to dilate your arteries and all
this kind of
stuff but it didn't solve the problem
and the problem keeps getting worse and
worse worse worse because they keep
because people kept eating the bad stuff
which was the fried foods no fried foods
no no fried fish no Fried Chicken no
fried potatoes no fried vegetables no
stir fried anything
nothing fried okay because when you eat
fried foods that the fat turns into
trans fats heterocyc greines and
acrylamides which
cause major damage to the walls of your
arteries and that's what caused the
arteries to be plugged okay was was this
inflammation caused by eating the um the
oils and the fried foods and people
continue today to pay the price people
eat those Foods
pay the price now if you get rid of all
those Foods or bad foods you save a lot
of money and you'll actually make money
okay by getting on our programs because
now you're saving a lot of money by
getting rid of all the bad foods that
are expensive and you can use some of
that money to buy your young jvid
products and get on the right programs
to support your kidneys support your
lungs support your heart support your
brain support your liver support your
lungs support your muscles support your
arteries support your veins support your
nerves support your carage ligaments
tendons connective tissue disc between
vertebrae bones all your glands
including you know your sex glands and
so forth your eyes your ears all that
requires these nutrients just think of
your heart
beating you know 50 to 70 times a
minute for a hundred years
247 your heart needs some support it
needs blood flow you have to keep those
little coronary arteries
open okay and that's why we come up with
the products we have okay with all that
said I'm gonna turn it over to you Becca
all right thank you so much Dr W now for
those of you who exercise and are out
doing physical of course your heartbeat
is going to be above 70 I know whenever
I'm doing my running Dr W and depending
on which exercise I do I get up to like
150 even so making sure that I have my
90 essential nutrients my essential
fatty acids which help C keep I'm
getting to that keep my blood clean my
ultimate daily classic to keep that
circulation flowing and then be
especially because I'm working out and
I'm sweating I do the rebound also like
Dr wallik is holding up and yes I prefer
the powders um they do have less sugar
and I they have more nutrients in them
and it's easy just to take a couple
Scoops put it in my water and go I don't
have to worry about it shaking Dr wck or
when I try to open it it
explodes because I can't always open it
the day before and then have it to
travel so with that being said Dr wellik
um you had mentioned you know the the
blood going out of the heart being
oxygenated and then as it goes through
all the veins and arteries and um
capillaries and then going back so
you've got the the outgoing and then you
have the return and the return has less
oxygen in it that's correct less oxygen
less nutrients less of everything
because your body has been sucking all
the goodies out okay along the trail
okay from the heart to wherever it's
going to the lungs and the heart and the
brain and the liver and the kidneys and
the muscles and the bones but the return
blood is low in everything is low in
nutrients and low in oxygen low in fluid
so it's a little thicker the Venus blood
is thicker than arterial blood doesn't
have the oxygen levels doesn't have the
food levels and so it's I mean you can
tell just by doing an analysis of a
blood sample whether it came from a vein
or an
artery so with that being said Dr wck if
there isn't a lot of oxygen and there
isn't a lot of nutrients in the blood as
it's leaving the heart that's even less
coming back that's correct that's why
people
die when you well when you have more
more more carbon dioxide no food you die
your heart dies your your liver dies
your lungs die your brain
dies and that's something that you found
in some of your studies referring to the
kidneys that the kidneys were losing
circulation there was really nothing
wrong with the kidney itself self other
than the blood wasn't flowing through it
yeah the arteries were
plugged and we wanted to do kidney
transplants but see they again they were
getting the wrong information they were
getting incomplete information just like
saying oh the arteries are plugged
because people are eating cholesterol no
no
no well it does have to do with the bad
foods but it's also not getting the
nutrients that the body needs in order
to have f function at its optimal best
right that is
correct you
get go ahead you get an A+ that's
correct oh I'll take it I'll take
it well Dr wck that we have a few hands
up with us and then we also have people
that are putting comments in the YouTube
chat for some reason I'm not seeing
Rumble today but let's go ahead and
answer some questions Dr wck
first let's go to Mike Mike go ahead and
unmute yourself if you would
please okay I'm un muted I can hear you
too how are you today what can what can
we do for you well I've been on
um um I have a enlarged prostate and
I've been on U medicine since
2015 and just this month I had a problem
where um I couldn't urinate so I'm in
Florida my doctor's in Maryland he
saidou going to have to go to the
emergency room and they put a catheter
in the next day I saw a urologist down
here they took the catheter out the
following day then I was back in the
emergency room the following week so so
far they've done a cystostomy they've
done a cat skin and they won't do a MRI
till the
12th um my doctor in Maryland
he's looked at everything he just thinks
it's enlarged and so I'm calling just to
I've listened to you guys on the radio
at night a lot of times and I'm just
trying to
learn okay well let's let's look at the
prostate okay um it has many
functions and um one of the things you
have to appreciate and let me ask you a
question before you had a blocked
urinary system how many times are you
waking up at night to urinate once three
times five times 10 once probably you
know unless something was weird you know
sometimes it' be twice but usually just
once okay how many times you're urinate
during the day is it frequent during the
day yes yes 10 times during the day you
know like once every couple of hours yes
yes okay all right and so um let's see
here do you have any tentis or ringing
in your ears no okay do you have any
balance problems any issues with that
balance or no
okay uh let's see here um um um do you
have anything going on with swallowing
voice
changes loss of sense of taste anything
like that no okay do you anything going
on with your fingers or
toes well my fingers um when I'm
sleeping sometimes they'll sort of fall
asleep if I got them in the wrong
direction okay not my toes not my toes
but my
fingers
okay uh do you have anything going on um
let's see here uh you say your prostate
is enlarged do they determine this with
a scan yeah with the CAT scan well I've
always had one but you know it this time
it's way up there like okay yeah and it
could be just a simple deficiency okay
of nutrients causing that um okay and so
there they don't seem too concerned
about wanting to get a biopsy anything
like that yes yes yes they want to do a
biopsy but they won't do it until I get
the MRI on Wednesday so I'm not in
Maryland I'm in Florida and I'm with new
PE new doctors that I um okay they're
from the Cleveland Clinic okay well keep
us informed on that but U basically um
you know you could have osteoprosis to
the skull squeezing the spinal cord and
the spinal cord is squeezing the nerves
um during the day and the evening and
that's why you're urinating so much
during the day because your spinal cord
is being squeezed by the skull and the
skull is telling the excuse me your your
spinal cord is telling your urinary
bladder to urinate during the day okay
because your position and so forth your
vertical and so
on the but women get the same problem
this is not only in in men but women
don't have a prostate gland so you can't
blame it on the prostate gland you know
you can have and you have some white
gray and silver hair all right this is
not due to aging this is due to a
nutritional deficiency that same
nutritional deficiency can cause
problems with connective tissue in the
walls of arteries and ve veins and your
urinary tubes and and and also in the
tubes inside the prostate gland and so
forth uh your hair color we can get your
hair color to come back in months okay
that's very easy okay you just have to
take the proper nutrients how much do
you weigh sir
okay all right and no high blood
pressure no diabetes none of that kind
of stuff well they at one point they
told me I had diabetes but I corrected
it On My Own by changing my diet and
riding my bicycle and I check my blood
sugar almost every day and it's between
85 and 90 good okay so I don't take any
medicine for diabetes okay good but I
take a blood pressure pill because they
you know he won't let me off of it but
sure okay I understand okay so we need
you to get rid of all the bad food I
want you get my book Dr Wall cooking
without the bad foods with 300 pages of
of um safe recipes and also safe cooking
methods then I want you to get to two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
there's one per 100 pounds of body
weight you're close enough to 200 lbs I
only weigh 142 and I take two healthy
brain and heart packs for a month I take
a full dose of breakfast at dinner time
and it has the core of the 90 cent of
nutrients and then by getting rid of the
bad foods you know the fried foods and
the processed meats and the oils and the
glutens and the wheat and the bar oats
and the buckwhat and the sugar and the
carbonated drinks including carbonated
water you'll save enough money to pay
for the supplements so it won't be a
burden to buy the supplements because
you're gonna be saving a lot of money by
getting rid of the bad foods and then I
also want you in addition to the two
healthy brand and heart ption month I
want you to take two bottles a month of
our MSM so you take three of those at
breakfast three at lunch at dinner time
they're going to support and promote
main repair cartilage ligaments tenons
connective tissue disc between a
vertebrae bone microphone itself
including the um making of white blood
cells your bone marrow and your red
blood cells and platelets and all that
kind of stuff um the MSM will help you
do that I want you to take our collagen
peptides get two of the little canisters
of collagen peptides you take a scoop
your morning drink SC your evening drink
um you use our rebound or sports drink
it comes in the Sticks sticks in a box
each stick has 100 nutrients in it we do
have the the um little canisters which
we showed you just a few moments ago
okay the canister has 36 servings and
there's a little scoop you put one scoop
of this powder into a bottle of water
and you get your H 100 100 nutrients we
do have the cans uh 12 oce cans there's
12 cans in a case but the cans do have
carbonation in them so I like to pop the
tops on two of them every night before I
go to bed put them in the refrigerator
so it'll be flat in the morning all the
bubbly gone by morning so I have one
with breakfast and one with lunch never
later than two or three in the afternoon
I don't want be staying up all night but
each of each serving of
the of the
um okay the rebound of the of the
rebound thank you each serving of the
rebound has 100 nutrients in it okay and
the healthy Brandon heart pack has 215
nutrients in it you know you're
absorbing when your hair color starts
coming back okay usually within two or
three weeks after you're starting it if
you've given up all the bad foods and
you're on good recipes and stay away
from the bad stuff you can absorb the
good stuff um your hair color will start
coming back in two to three weeks
usually takes about um anywhere from two
to three months for it to completely you
know grow out properly the same color it
was when you were a
teenager we have people who ball
like a bowling ball for 40 years in
three months time they had all their
hair back at the hair color they when
they were 12 okay this is very simple
stuff okay and of course the doctors are
frustrated with this because once you
know that you can prevent and reverse
all these problems with
nutrition you don't
need drugs to deal with the
symptoms because the symptoms are gone
when you solve the problem the symptoms
are gone but the medical treatment tends
to be
drugs that treat the symptoms as opposed
to getting rid of the problem okay so we
we come at this from two different
directions so you know keep in touch
with us just remember uh the book goes
into the history of going from wood and
coal to fuel for thousands and thousands
and thousands of years of electricity
plants only need three minerals we need
60 uh Hell's Kitchen tells you what's
happened to humanity since we went to
electricity there's no ashes associated
with in your your house with generating
or using electricity for heat and
cooking and that kind of stuff air
conditioning okay and so once we went to
electricity and we went to hydroelectric
and damning up all the river so there's
no more bottom land suddenly now we're
in trouble and doctor said oh you know
this is all genetic stuff all autoimmune
stuff just eat well you get everything
you need and come to me and I'll give
you a drug that'll relieve your symptoms
okay and so get that book Hell's Kitchen
get the book it's all in your head get
the book that wall re Revolution
and the information will add 25 to 50
healthy years your life you'll save
enough money by getting rid of all the
bad foods to pay for the supplements in
fact you'll actually be on the positive
side you actually save enough money by
getting rid of all the bad
foods and um all the gas lean you spend
on your trips to the doctors and the
pharmacy and Clinics and all that kind
of stuff
um okay and so do keep in touch with us
now well will somebody get in touch with
me with all this that I read that
so Mike yes yeah so Mike um if you're
what you can do is you can go to YouTube
you can find a replay of this program
and be able to relist to it and write it
down if you are working with a
youngevity associate already get back
with them in order to get your products
on their way to you
okay okay so I can go to YouTube and
find this recording yeah yes you can
find all the recordings from our
programming on our critical Health News
Channel on YouTube or on rumble or on
Facebook we are just critical
Health okay well I appreciate it thank
you so much okay keep you're very
welcome I
will all right thank you so much Mike
and Dr wck let's just move right over to
MIMA Mima go go ahead and unmute
yourself I want
to well that was my grandchildren my
name's Leah and uh they've named my
phone as mimo's phone so thank you very
much I enjoy watching the program I do
have a qu couple questions um Epstein
bar virus I have that it's actively
replicating in my system and I wanted to
know if there's a way that I can um like
kill it and get it out out of my system
or is it something that just goes in
remission are you taking
already um I just got started with a
health coach and I'm hoping that I have
some products G to be at my house when I
get home today okay yeah you need the
essential nutrients to support your
immune system and then to put the gun to
the virus's head and kill it we have
colloidal silver it's been used for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years saf
put a dropper full under the left side
of your tongue a dropper full under your
right side of your tongue four times a
day when you wake up in the morning
about 10 minutes before each meal and
you can even do it again before bedtime
I do that and I don't have a problem I
probably don't have a problem because
I've been doing this for I don't know 20
years
okay okay all right but this you don't
need okay thank you NE may I ask you a
couple questions about uh
livestock livestock go for it little bit
different is there a way to prevent pink
eye in
cattle yeah cut their eyes
out okay Dr W that is not a
solution not a if they're exposed to the
bug they're going to get pink eye okay
so it just depends on you know if if
you're visiting somebody's farm and they
have pink eye in their livestock and you
go home and you hug your dairy cow then
you're going to give her pink eye okay
it's one of those things okay okay so
it's not a mineral
deficieny or something
that
allows think I think I'm familiar with
this
virus you can also have yes you can also
have you know some um vitamin A
deficiencies okay but if they're eating
hay which is green they have beta katene
in there they're going to get plenty of
vitamin A so that's that's not the
issue okay um my second livestock
question is about
sheep I'd like to know if there's a
natural way to prevent uh worms and
parasites and sheep since they get that
so
badly okay well again it comes down to
um
contamination on your shoes manure from
somebody else's Farm somebody delivering
hey to you and they've got the the
manure in their feet and so forth and so
what you need to do is have a um uh one
of these you know 4 inch high trays you
know um in front of your barns in front
of your house in front of your Gates
going out into the pastures and anybody
anybody coming and you're going to have
you know disinfectant in there okay and
people have to stand in a half inch of
that um disinfectant for their boots and
their shoes and so forth for about um
one minute you just can't step through
it okay no you got to step you got to be
in it for one minute and kill any
parasites and kill viruses and bacteria
and fungus and
yeast thank you very much you
bet it's cheaper than a veterinarian
coming out constantly
all right thank you so very much for
joining us today and Dr wallik so I am
I'm a little bit familiar with cattle
and pink eye and taking the clal silver
that you recommended and putting a
little spray a fine Mist on the top of
that bottle instead of doing the
droppers then as you're out in the herd
which I know some herds are a little
more wild than others others they come
right up to me they let me p
just do quick little sprays in the eyes
whenever you're out there you're not
touching you're not doing any CPE of
cross contamination you don't have to
get them to hold still while you do the
droppers but that little fine Mist
sprayer you can get close enough do it
quickly they don't even know and it does
amazing stuff on pink eye whether it's
in livestock or in humans Dr wet because
I've used it well there you go without
fail
so yes uh colloidal silver folks you're
going to have to drink quarts of it if
you're G to if you want to turn blue but
for regular use like Dr wallik
recommends even daily use just a dropper
on each side of the mouth couple times
of the day you are not going to turn
blue and it actually gives the body that
extra little boost to be able to work
through the things that we're exposed to
yes we've been doing this you know all
through this pandemic and we see so many
people they come from all over the world
and they run up and hug you and shake
your hands and who knows what airplanes
they were on with who had the bug and
this that and the other and we've been
blessed with our team being very healthy
all through this because we use the clal
silver faithfully and let you say oh
you're going to turn blue
well you're going to have to eat a lot
of
quarters your silver quarters Dr W like
it's not just any quarter because now
they've got like copper fillings and all
mixed metals and craziness well let's go
ahead and go to the next hand that is up
Dr willik actually I want a quick a
quick little question here um in our
YouTube chat so Corey says I have a bad
ankle I'm on blood thinners uh because
of a blood clot and Pulmonary ambois
uh the ankle was broken or is broken and
it caused the damage in the left leg
what Dr wallik would you recommend for
somebody based on a 100 pounds who has
experienced blood clot pulmonary
embolism broken
bones and they're currently on a blood
thinner okay well at 100 pounds uh there
either a young person or you know a lady
usually excuse me um he is six foot tall
and he weighs 257 pounds well there's a
difference you're welcome 257 six foot
tall 57 years old 200 pounds at six foot
okay no no no it's six foot tall
27 pounds I see sorry I had muted
myself thank you ruthellen you're
welcome okay yeah and so um they need a
lot of nutrition when you're 277 pounds
57 I don't know why I keep getting 77
okay okay 257 all right now this person
needs to get rid of all the bad foods
they need to get a hold of that book Dr
Cook about the bad foods for 300 pages
of safe recipes and safe cooking methods
absolutely none of the bad foods no
fried foods no processed Meats no oils
no glutens no wheat no R oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbonat drinks
even the diet ones got to go and and
carbonated water needs to go and 257 I
would go they have all this stuff going
on um especially with um blood clots
okay that can cause stroke and that kind
of stuff um then fractures there's a lot
going on in this person okay so they
need to um again the two healthy brain
and heart packs two bottes of month of
the ultimate daily classic tablets for
circulation take three of those three
times a day ultimate daily classic
tablets again uh let's see here I'm
going to have two botes a month of the
MSM so I take three of those three times
a day rebuild cartle ligaments tenons
connective tissue disc between vertebr
bone makes bone itself and in the
healthy brain and heart pack it has
three efas and three EFA pluses and I
since I'm taking two doses a day of
everything okay okay I'm getting three
efas twice a day and three FAA pluses
twice a day I weigh 142 and that will
prevent blood clots okay because blood
clots are a deficiency of of the
essential fatty acids very important
here okay the fractures okay we need to
throw in the extra
ultimate and see here we also throw in
the um uh collagen peptides uh scoop
with that with the morning drink with
the evening drink that'll be two of the
small canisters of and peptide powder
and then also the U FX I would take an
ounce of that twice a day at 257 pounds
I take an ounce of the U FX twice a day
and I would get our if they have a
garden okay I would get our blooming
minerals and use our blooming minerals
in the garden so that the vegetables
that they're growing will have more
minerals in it so everything they put in
their mouth should have more minerals
okay very important okay use our
blooming minerals in our Gardens and
around their cherry trees and right
cherry pie all that kind of stuff okay
and don't forget gluten-free pizza um I
have three Poached Eggs this morning and
a nice wedge of gluten-free pizza okay
with all these vegetables on top of it
along with um yogurt and berries
and uh my all my supplements and
everything including my rebound and so
forth it it's it's an amazing thing when
you take all this stuff I'm getting a
nutrients four to six times a day
depending what's going on I I'm taking a
100 nutrients four to six times a day
and in in a couple of months I'll be 84
years old and you know most people think
I'm in my 50s or early 60s when they
look at me they can't believe that I'm
84 okay this is this is simple stuff but
I've been taking this stuffs I've been
taking large doses of these nutrients
since I was nine years old okay I was
taking the same stuff they were given to
200 PB 400 PB calves and people say oh
you're just eating alala no I was eating
the Alfalfa pellets that were enriched
with vitamins and minerals there
vitamins and minerals were in the alala
that I was getting the nutrients from
okay and so that was the important thing
and of course um with that knowledge you
know we're able to we were able to get
rid of things like um uh let's see here
oh cyob brosis I'm the guy that found
the cause renion cure of CIS brosis
thought to be a genetic birth effect I'm
the guy working with Jerry Lewis I'm the
guy who found the cause Ren and cure of
musie gave it to Jerry Lewis he took it
to the musie association they fired
Jerry Lewis sarily on let's see was
September 4th 2011 they fired him put a
gag order him so he couldn't say
anything and cancelled the um his um ton
the next day and his ton over 46 years
had raised
2.6 billion dollar and they some earily
terminated him because he brought them
the Cure well he died a couple years
later but he
knew in his heart we had been successful
because I had talked to him many many
times after they put the gag AR on him
and but he couldn't say anything but I
could share stuff with him and I could
hear him smiling on the other end of the
phone because he knew had found the
cause prevention cure of mus also found
the cause and prevention of sedam and
death syndrome doctors were saying for
years and years and years and years and
years and years that s death syndrome
was caused by mother's laying on the
babies and
suffocating I had to get my attorney
Jonathan eort and I we sued the FDA
eight times in federal court on that one
subject got these nutrients put in a
baby form was infam and Similac and the
like we prevailed in all areas we got
the nutrients put in the baby formulas
and within 90 days after that happened
those three diseases just disapp
appeared those three things just
disappeared you don't hear about those
three things anymore because we put the
nutrients in the baby fals and so we're
very proud that we're responsible for
that it's amazing Dr wallak what happens
whenever you give the body the
nourishment that it needs because we
weren't made from
just
sugar and bottled oils I me we weren't
made from those things we've got to give
the body back the things that it was
made from the things that create healthy
your cells and as long as we're doing it
in intentionally making sure that it's
going into the body being consistent on
it there's a lot of things that we can
do in writing our own health Journeys Dr
W yeah and of course again this was
recognized but by authorities and
various organizations and um I I did get
uh the
okay the uh let's see here this is the
from the the United Nations 2015 this is
United Nations okay um to see let's see
here I won the award okay A Lifetime
Achievement Award from the United
Nations they only give out two or three
of those every couple years or so very
proud of that and then in
2011 I actually got
the CLA Schwarz award for discovering
the cause R and cure C brosis that's me
with the Gearhart shouser receiving that
award okay
2011 okay very proud
of yep you've done a lot Dr wallik and
that's why we're here today is to be
able to provide information to others in
regards to the research that you have
done the research that you've been
acknowledged for but not in the way that
it's reaching the masses at that time
and that's what we're doing today let's
go ahead and go to one more hand Dr wall
before you have to go yes and Ted go
ahead and unmute yourself if you would
please you're on live with Dr
wallik hi hi Dr Wall extreme pleasure uh
my honor to uh to talk with you have a
chance to ask question kind words how
can we help you so I'm I'm I'm doing
pretty well I'm I'm taking the 90
centrals for many months now um I uh
still have I'm struggling with blood
pressure a little bit it can Spike kind
of high so I'm wondering uh okay how
much you weigh I weigh about 200 pounds
okay any other issues back problems how
many times at night you wake up to
urinate once three times five times none
two three times two three times okay I
Stay Well hydrated I usually have tea
late in the day and if I wake up you
know I I'll have to urinate but what
about what about ringing in the ears
have tonight rain in the
Years um I think I might a little
buzzing once in a while anything like
that okay what about anything like um
dizziness or balance problems you have
to use a water pain nope okay no blood
pressure no diabetes no I do have some
blood pressure okay one last question
um let's see here
um do you ever uh have to um let's see
see
here
uh where I want to go here um do you
ever oh do you ever get sleepy after a
meal do you ever you know eat a big meal
eat dinner time and you're sitting there
watching TV and you fall asleep anything
like that yeah no not sure okay that's
reactive hypoglycemia your body releases
a lot of insulin knocks your blood
pressure down oh excuse me your blood
sugar you said you had a little blood
pressure
issue right yes okay so at um 200 pounds
I want you to take get rid of all the
bad foods no fried foods no processed
Meats no oils no gluten no wheat BR R
notes no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet ones got to go and no
carbonated water no bubbly water I do
want you to take two of the healthy Brin
and heart packs per month you know ramp
up to the little higher um numbers of
nutrients a full dose everything twice a
day staying away from the bad foods
you'll save enough money to pay for the
healthy brain and heart pack two dose a
day I want you to get two botes a month
of the ultimate daily classic tablets I
take three of those breakfast lunch and
dinner I also want you to take the
collagen peptides take a um a scoop of
that with your morning drink the evening
drink or you get two BS a month of the
ultimate daily classic tablets three
words ultimate daily classic tablets and
um take three breakfast three dinner
time if you're on medication for high
blood pressure don't cold turkey off of
that but as blood pressure comes comes
down you can slowly reduce medication
based on the numbers usually within two
to six weeks um your blood pressure be
down in the normal range I also want you
get our swee EAS get two b a month of
our swee EAS it can take three twice a
day and that will prevent you from
getting that hypoglycemia because I
don't want you to fall asleep when
you're driving okay eat a big dinner and
you're driving it get drowsy that's
that's why people cross the center line
and kill themselves kill somebody else
so when you have active hypoglycemia we
need you to get that sweet e so we
resolve that problem okay three of those
today we'll do I did have a question
give us a call every a couple of weeks
because your blood pressure is going to
be good your reactive hypoglycemia is
going to go away that ring in the ears
is going to go away okay and the you
know do those additional things can can
I ask how much does it matter dude to
eliminate gluten I've cut way back on my
gluten but it's really hard with my wife
does cooking and she she's still you
know we still have some glut here's the
deal um what if you only shoot yourself
in the head once instead of five
times once is enough yeah once is enough
and so uh two meals a week of gluten
instead of you getting really serious
problems within a year or two it might
take you three to four
years okay it's just G to be a little
bit slower but you know but you gotta
get you got to be zero
gluten say the word if you say the word
that's a challenge to get to zero gluten
work on it I understand I understand but
you got to sometimes you just leave it
on the plate and don't eat it yeah and
you're stove here see I'm making some
rice
yeah I know I've heard you say eat like
an Asian right yeah you want to eat like
an Asian and that's why because Asian
Southern Asian they they live okay in
the United States depending on whose
numbers you're looking at our our life
expectancy is 73 to 7
you look at Japan they're 84 they
essentially live 10 years longer than we
do and then China is a great great study
uh they have two populations in the
north they live on wheat in the South
they live on Rice the ones in the South
live to be 75 the ones in the north live
to be
71 okay yep so this is this is
unimpeachable information and so it's
one of those things where you really
have to watch it uh you will be blessed
with a longer healthier life spend more
time with the people you
love okay and I apologize for I keep
looking at the clock here I got two more
minutes and now your time is up doc oh
so thank you I've been given strict
orders to make sure that you are not
late for your next appointment so I just
want to thank you again for joining us
here Monday through Friday from 12 to
is on daily with Doc
so thank you again Dr wlik you have a
fabulous day and happy Easter happy Good
Friday to everybody who um takes the
time to consider the day and the events
that happened um so many many years ago
on the day not so much this specific day
but this is the day that we kind of
observe it in the Christian faith so
happy Easter everybody hope you all have
a wonderful wonderful weekend if I could
get my co-hosts up with me I just want
to give a special shout out to ruthellen
Sanchez and Marilyn pazera um the two of
them were working extra hard today as
they were going through and making sure
that the information was being shared in
the chat monitoring our YouTube and
Facebook groups sharing information to
me so that if we got to it or we had
time we could get to it but folks if we
did not get to your your question please
use our website and contact us option um
and send in your questions if you are
working with a youngevity associate
already or somebody referred you
specifically to this program please get
back with them and say thank you for
sharing this information with me how do
I myself get on the products that they
were talking about and if somebody
shared this program with you it's
possible that they may have their own
special way of
ordering if nobody has ever shared this
information with you you found it on
your own and you have never tried any of
the youngevity products we do have a
shopping cart in store we have a store
with a shopping cart on daily with
doc.com but again that's for people who
are not not currently working with
somebody who are associated with
youngevity now rouselle and Sanchez she
does like extra Duty with me she keeps
me in line and I am so thankful for that
um all the things that she has learned
as I have stretched her and taken her
out of her comfort zone um thank you
Ruth Allen for being with you're welcome
appreciate that and Marilyn also and the
tech new technology that she's learning
and using her skills that she has from
her past careers and life in making sure
that the information is being shared in
the chat so she's doing a fabulous job
with that and helping the people in I
just greatly appreciate my team even the
ones that aren't here I know that
there's a couple of them that are doing
some marketing for us um without being
here in the show but it takes a team
folks and if you have any skills that
you would like to utilize to help
promote Wellness not sick management but
promote Wellness promote healthier
living promote being able to build an
additional stream of income helping
others there is nothing wrong with being
thanked for helping others and sharing
information with them about things that
they can do to be empowered and take
their health back take their life back
even financially so we just want to make
sure that you know that there are
opportunities
available get back with the person that
shared this program with you or use our
website contact us and we'll be able to
get you in contact with a certified
holistic health
coach to help you figure out what it is
exactly that you want to do for yourself
or your
community we have a phone number with a
call team standing by at 855
377 for those who have never spoken to
anybody about Dr wallik or the
youngevity products at all and I do want
to throw in Dr wck has many many
Publications and if you are interested
in getting some of his books make sure
you go to drj wall.com he didn't mention
it in the show um but I want to make
sure that I mention it because that's
how he makes his income he has
completely turned over the business of
youngevity to to his son and his wife
and they're in control of that he does
not get a paycheck from youngevity and
he did that on purpose he did not want
people to say well you're only pushing
these products because you make a buck
off of them and that is not true he does
not get a paycheck from youngevity so
visit his website drj wall.com
and get get a get a book start gaining
knowledge we even have some eBooks there
some digital books for those of you who
use CD players there's CDs there as well
that you can listen to previous messages
that Dr wallik has made available that
have been
impactful very impactful in the lives of
others and I'm working on putting those
CDs into digital downloads as well so
thanks for listening to me Rambo my name
is Becca dukes and on behalf of daily
withth
do.com have a wonderful weekend and we
will see you next week Monday through
Wednesday next week as we are going to
take some personal time
off 12 to
12:50 Pacific time here on daily withth
doc
zoom.com bye for now happy Easter
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]